ah Europe home of Florida football
nothing says Munich like the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers it's a famed American
hawkskin player uh this happens
everywhere
it's all about the team baby isn't that
right Tyler Lockett you know my name wow
Russ always said that's what our numbers
were for
eign
[Music]
not a single one of my seven rings is
worth more than this pretzel let's go
don't worry it's no longer dangerous yes
the best footballer no no no that could
not matter less
ugly American so how do you keep getting
better as you get older the trick is to
get the hell away from New Jersey
he looked grunk not every white guy with
a beer is drunk oh wait that is grunk
today except
[Music]
and Mariota with a five yard pass too
I don't know I don't care to take the
lead over the coachless Panthers
God damn it I'm out Michael's
and they used to mean something that's
right Al also check out Amazon's
Thursday night football basketball
football finally basketball players
talking over football about basketball
and maybe football
foreign